alors jean françois kahn comme vous êtes
un homme de solutions parce que c'est
vrai vous avez toujours à coeur de
trouver des solutions non c'est vrai
mais entendu on va vous demander de
trouver des solutions à un certain
nombre de problèmes mais comme vous être
extrêmement bavards jean-françois 4 on
va vous faire il une interview chrono
alors le principe de l'inter du chrono
c'est très simple d'abord on définit le
temps que vous aurez pour répondre à la
question
d'accord une fois qu'on a ce temps je
vous pose la question et vous avez mis
plus six mois pour répondre top chrono
dites stop quand vous voulez jean
françois kahn
56 secondes vous avez dit stop à 56
secondes quand vous avez 56 secondes
pour répondre à la question était
congelé durrer vous allez avoir du mal
avec ce alors vous écoutez bien la
question quelles solutions avez-vous
ce que vous êtes un homme de solutions
contre les jeunes qui se réunissent dans
les cages d'escalier
quand il fait froid dehors
56 secondes eh bien d'abord on leur
fournit les vêtements plus chauds pour
qu'ils étaient en froid on les réunit on
essaye de leur tenir des propos comment
dirais-je assez enthousiasmant pour que
pour que ça les mobilise pour que c'est
laid dynamise et pour que cette on leur
fournit un projet une raison de se
battre et cette raison de se battre les
églises et chauffe comme on dirait geler
leur sert de chaleur naturelle et
finalement c'est ça qui à mon avis le
père mais n'ont pas pu avoir froid mais
d'oublier complètement le froid
c'est en toi
bien alors vous avez compris le principe
maintenant on va calculer le temps de
votre deuxième réponse à la deuxième
question vous dites stop quand vous
voulez top chrono atop
en seconde quelles solutions avez-vous
pour la coiffure 2stv
à mon avis le mieux c'est c'est de tout
couper
absolument tout coupé et puis attendre
éventuellement de voir ce qui repousse
tout le monde a compris attention top
chrono
vous y sentir avec 27 secondes très bien
alors jean françois kahn quelles
solutions avez-vous contre la calvitie
d'autres cons alors d'abord vous
imaginez bien que si j'avais une
solution et bien j'en aurais profité et
j'apparaîtrai devant vous avec une
chevelure abondante donc j'ai tout
essayé
rien ne marche autrement dit je peux
vous répondre solennellement et c'est
très important pour des milliers de gens
que quoi qu'on pense pour la calvitie il
n'y a pas de solution
ouais
attention calcule le temps de votre
prochaine réponse top chrono
top 21 secondes jean françois kahn vous
qui êtes un homme de solutions quelles
solutions avez-vous pour retrouver ben
laden
aubin
à à mon avis alors il ya des pendules
c'est parce qu'on n'a pas essayé le
pense c'est vrai et je pense le pendule
ça peut être très efficace pour
retrouver mes manettes l'autre façon
c'est dire qu'il ya un magot quelque
part ouais de mettre des gens autour il
attendre qu'il arrive pour le piqué est
à ce moment là quand ils arrivent pour
le piquer bon lui saute dessus c'est
quand même bon
chrono vous y trouvez 28 secondes allez
on se concentre jean françois kahn
quelles solutions avez-vous pour
remplacer voici le lundi matin
ben alors justement je me suis beaucoup
interrogée sur ce problème alors il par
certains aspects c'est absolument
remplaçable naturellement et surtout que
et je me suis dit comme c'est le lundi
la seule façon de remplacer voici lundi
c'était de créer un autre journal le
lundi et c'est pour ça que j'ai pris
tous les risques que vous avez souligné
pour créer le journal marianne quand le
lundi
[Applaudissements]
alors bien c'est non sans vous
concentrez vous c'est très simple 1 vous
voyez il ya un compteur qui tourne vous
le voyez donc quand je vais dire top
chrono le temps qui apparaîtra à ce
moment là sur l'écran sera celui qui
vous est imparti pour donner votre
réponse tom cruise
vous avez deux secondes déjà pas chuté à
vous avez deux secondes dont je vous
pose la question vous aurez deux
secondes pour y répondre quand je dirais
top chrono à l'envi dit page 37 de votre
livre sujet de lionel jospin j'espère
qu'il continuera à apporter sa vision
des choses au débat parce que je peux
vous dire moi en tous les cas c'est que
chaque fois qu'il le fait c'est pas un
scoop top chrono oui mais c'est utile
génial
non ce n'était même pas une question ça
se vend bien merci alors maintenant on
va parler de chevènement j'aimerais que
commissaire les soutiens l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur c'est très bien
véronique attention jeu on va parler de
chevènement là je laisse tourner et
voilà et puis quand je vais dire top
chrono asepam à quarante et une secondes
voilà donc au sujet de chevènement vous
dites page 27 il a affirmé que jospin
chirac c'était la même chose blanc
bonnet bonnet blanc comme disait notre
ami du plot et il vous dit il n'a pas le
droit il n'a pas du tout le droit de se
comporter de cette manière top chrono
non je crois que jean pierre chevènement
pour qui j'ai du respect qui a apporté à
la gauche qui a porté au gouvernement
notamment sur le cas de la sécurité n'a
pas le droit d'être aussi ingrat parce
que l'ingratitude en politique aussi
c'est pas un exemple à donner à la
société alors c'est vrai que jean pierre
chevènement il a eu la confiance de
lionel jospin je dirais même qu'il a eu
son infection dans des périodes
difficiles et je crois que la
comparaison avec chirac était trop dur
et trop injuste
vous voulez que j'aille encore si vous
avez 10 ans d'un surcroît il a contribué
à la dispersion de la gauche à la
décrédibilisation et je pense
personnellement qu'il a été un de ceux
qui ont contribué 5 à l'élimination de
la gauche le 21 avril heureusement
dépassera le 21 avril l'avenir est
devant nous ouais
obama
vous êtes en train de réussir votre
attention au passage chirac peuvent
chrono 24 secondes alors page 139 de
votre livre vous dites pour que l'état
dispose d'autorité il faut que ses
dirigeants soient exemplaires à
commencer par le président de la
république top chrono honnêtement j'ai
pas besoin de 24 secondes oui c'est
essentiel quand on veut incarner
l'autorité de l'état il faut de ce point
de vue être exemplaire je pense que
lionel jospin l'était voilà et je pense
que jacques chirac qui a déjà une longue
vie politique a été plusieurs fois
premier ministre ministre une fois
président la république est maintenant y
compris avec ma voix président de la
république doit donner l'exemple ouais
dernière question
attention elle concernera véronique
genest
cours
ça va j'ai trés selon les chiffres de la
chance voilà pourquoi aimez-vous
véronique genest
d'abord parce que je la trouve
ravissante intelligente vive et je
voudrais bien que toutes les
commissaires de françois comme julie
lescaut c'est à dire comme véronique
genest je pense que c'est aussi le signe
de la féminisation de la police bravo
véronique
gagnon l'insécurité rio
gauche s'est délité chuck lorre milanais
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus